one of the things that sustains us
through this is food lots of us are
cooking more maybe eating too much but
plenty of restaurants have either closed
or are struggling to survive doing
takeout but everybody's got to eat
including healthcare workers who are run
off their feet
so as Abigail Beeman reports a new
initiative put two and two together to
sustain the line in a flash kovat 19
changed everything for this couple right
on their Toronto restaurants third
anniversary going from earning or making
a living rather to making nothing being
very scared waking up in the middle of
the night in cold sweats but while
figuring out how to pay the bills feed
their children get their laid off staff
hooked up with employment insurance and
launched a delivery service somehow the
earth Sulis and crisp rift is found the
time to think about others in need needs
to get to the hospitals we want to give
our time and our food to feed the
healthcare workers the frontline workers
that's right while facing their own
frightening lis uncertain future the
owners of fat lamb cozinha wanted to
donate to health care workers these
people are heroes you know they need
anything we can do to make their life
easier
they couldn't quite figure out how to do
it alone but fortunately a small team
was already cooking up a solution our
mission is really really simple we're
trying to save small food businesses
because 80% of these food businesses
might not survive the crisis at the same
time we're trying to feed the really
deserving frontline healthcare heroes
Aaron Solomon is a native Montrealer and
one of the guys behind sustain the line
the pandemic initiative pairs
restaurants ready to deliver with people
across North America who want to donate
meals to health care workers donors like
lawyer Darlene Tinelli
I really feel for people who still have
to go to work and without whom none of
us could confront ssin when she heard
about sustained the line from another
law firm she encouraged her own to get
on board and they did just a minute to
get out of our own heads and our own
worries and think about other piece
I think is what the team gravitated
towards her firm has already supported
two restaurants including fat Lam
cozinha on this day they're dropping off
30 meals at North York General Hospital
it means a lot to receive meals like
this and nourishes our bodies our
doctors are working 24 hours our
anesthesiologists go to codes they work
in ICU emerge yo are our nurses are
being redeployed our nurses are working
in the recovery room 24 hours as well
Solomon is busy he estimates sustained
the line has already seen more than
$100,000 in donations in its first three
weeks donors are stepping up across
North America in a number of American
and Canadian cities the list is growing
the project doesn't take a penny for any
of it I think that crisis like the
coronavirus crisis brings out both the
worst and the best in people and I think
we all have to think for ourselves what
side of ourselves do we want to have
brought out we see the good that this is
doing literally every hour we gave them
our name and sort of hey we want to be
part of this and all of a sudden boom we
have donations already delivering to
hospitals fat lamp coziness as long-term
care homes are next and sustain the line
says they're happy to feed the idea to
others who want to help more essential
workers if you out there would like to
copy what we're doing contact me and
I'll help you set it up if you want to
do it for grocery store workers you want
to do it for paramedics go ahead and do
it Solomon says it's important for
people to understand the need isn't
going away anytime soon neither it seems
is the desire to give back
[Music]